the time being 9 30 i'd like to call the
work session order and i would remind
everybody that while we are in here
assume that the mics are live
uh because it is going out um
so that people can watch us and see what
what is going on
um
just a reminder there's been a couple of
uh gaffes in other committees
with people thinking that because they
were on a break that all the bikes were
shut off they are not necessarily off
with that
i will open the work session on house
bill
we'll see what we get done today as i
said earlier
in one of our meetings
it is my intention to do straw polls on
any proposed amendments i know that the
commissioner probably has brought
something that
they need to have included in it because
it will take a little bit of time before
an actual exact session next week to get
an amendment done
but first we asked the commissioner and
her department
to
bring us some additional information
to answer some questions that members
who are not here asked
but we will
ask her to provide that information
and uh commissioner welcome
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee it's good to be with you again
um so
we have a lot of materials to pass out
today in response to some of the
questions from the committee
and so i hope you'll bear with us as
we take up each item we'll pass out the
materials
rather than giving you a stack of paper
all at one point
and because we know what happens people
start reading ahead and asking questions
or it can be confusing to understand
which document we're referencing um so
thank you
mr chairman for providing us with the
couple of items that committee members
had elevated to you i think the first
request was for an acronyms list um
we talked about it last time when it
comes to the funding for transportation
it is a little bit of an
alphabet soup
so i think there had been
a list of acronyms in the back of one of
the early presentations but we have a
separate acronym list
definition sheet that we can pass out
today
and my thanks to glenn davison who's
going to be the one helping to pass that
out of the paper
and and just walk around and drop it you
know um
this is very informal and at every place
that there is a mic would probably be
the best way
and then at the last meeting we had a
lot of discussion around toll credits
and specifically a request that came in
from the city of keene
so also with me today i'd spoken to
these documents but i have the original
email that i received from the city
from the city manager and then the
response that we provided from the
department so those can be passed out
also
in terms the maps
for the section of highway as well as
to identify the locations of the sound
walls that we're installing so those can
be passed out also
so i believe those were
the items
um that weren't necessarily going to be
discussed today but we had follow-up to
provide
documentation on
and then there was a number of other
items that had come up
first of all
we had been made aware that there might
be a request from the town of hudson
to perhaps
advocate that the hudson boulevard
project be reintroduced into the 10-year
plan
i did have a chance to talk with
representative ulri from hudson earlier
this week
he
he and i talked through the history of
the project and we talked about
the various types of funding that are
available for transportation projects
but what would probably be the most
suitable
in terms of funding uh work
um
this project you know
and talking about it with him and i
shared this with the committee last time
hudson boulevard
would be constructed on a portion of
the right-of-way that was identified for
the old circumferential highway so the
department did construct a portion of
the circumferential really the sagamore
bridge
between nashua and hudson but there had
been this vision to have a
highway that connected all the way up to
litchfield
that project
we went through the environmental
permitting process
many years ago now and
the degree of impacts were such that the
project never moved forward beyond the
construction of the portions that the
department completed
a few years ago the town of hudson had
expressed interest in
building a two-lane highway not a
four-lane highway as was originally
planned on a segment of the layout from
the circumferential and that's what they
were going to call hudson boulevard
the town had intended to pursue some
federal discretionary grants and so in a
previous 10-year plan
there was language introduced that
allowed the department to
work with the town
but our coordination would be limited to
reviewing the documents that they
provided
and supporting them identifying the
design standards but the town would have
been responsible for actually advancing
the project
the town did apply for grants they were
unsuccessful and so the project has
languished since
um but there still is concerns about the
degree of congestion on route 3a which
is low road in the town of hudson
and so there is interest in exploring
you know building another roadway that
would
relieve some of that congestion
and make it easier for those traveling
both to hudson and within hudson
um so what representative already and i
talked about was perhaps a feasibility
study to go back and look at
why the circumference will never move
forward
look more closely at the proposed
alignment
of the original corridor and the
department had proposed an alternate
alignment
at one point in time
and just try and figure out whether this
project truly is feasible and more
importantly what the actual design and
construction costs would be
um so we need a little bit more time as
i mentioned this was not a project that
was led by the department and we have
reached out to the town of hudson
and the town engineer has provided us
with all the information that he has
they hired a consultant to
scope the project and apply for the
grant funds
it also had the regional planning
commission and nashua rpc had done some
work
um and so we now have all of that
material so we can estimate what it
would cost to complete a feasibility
study but we need a little bit more time
to do that this is all sort of coming
together in the last week or so
order of magnitude wise we're thinking
maybe as much as a million dollars
because this would be a very
labor-intensive project from the
perspective of all the data we'd have to
collect you know what
stalled this project previously was the
environmental impact so we'd have to go
back and look closely at what went
delineation and
depending on how much work was done
by the town
we'll be trying to fill in those gaps to
understand whether a project really
could be undertaken
but we need some more time to refine
those numbers
in terms of color of money to pay for
that
hudson boulevard if constructed really
would not serve the turnpike it would be
more of a local road
and so
at this point we don't believe it would
be appropriate to fund it with turnpike
revenues
and plus as you know we have
seen a reduction in turnpike revenues
which led to us delaying some of the
existing approved capital project work
um so we think it would be most
appropriate to look at federal funds for
this study um
and so we need some more time as well to
understand what the impact would be on
other projects in the 10-year plan
but we are going to try and get that
information pulled together by early
next week
and we did also explain that the
department is just estimating and
scoping a project
at the end of the day the town of hudson
really has to make the request that this
committee consider any additions
and so we made them aware of the
continuation of the public hearing on
february 10th and also suggested that
once we have the information pulled
together concerning what they should be
asking for and that they submit
something in writing to the committee as
well
thank you representative eaton
commissioner you said that this would be
a very labor-intensive project so if
they make the request if the funding
went in
does that slow down any of the projects
that we're currently looking at because
you've got limited resources we all know
and
this is a
last gasp
throw them throw into the pool
um so this is some of the things that
we've been talking about internally we
likely would hire a consultant to
support us in advancing this effort um
we did think it would be prudent to
maybe
have some public informational meetings
and maybe some workshops with the town
before we would launch into the full
feasibility study um just to hear
feedback
and understand what
really is the vision when it comes to
hudson boulevard
like i said this was not a d.o.t
initiated project it was something that
was town led
so
we might phase even the feasibility
study into a public engagement period
and then the data collection period and
then sort of recommendations and
suggested
paths forward
um just so i'm clear uh trying to figure
out where we go from here on this issue
you will be bringing
additional information
hopefully in a week
um and then obviously if the town is
serious they'll they'll come in at the
continued public hearing and talk about
it
what what i'm looking at is i'd hoped to
do the executive session that afternoon
but if we want to make changes i don't
see that
actually getting finalized that
afternoon and we do have a continued uh
executive session done
but the the goal of the speaker and
myself is to finish with this by the end
of february
um
we may not be able to include
this portion in that i'm just thinking
outside right now
um
before that deadline to to get it done
and get it to the senate but then the
senate always says
um
they're
their champion over there i'm sure but
again it's a zero-sum game so we'll be
looking forward to
whatever you and the
the town can bring in next week and then
decide whether or not we can incorporate
it into an amendment
uh to house bill 2022
that kind of the way the rest of the
committee sees it
okay thank you
yeah
yeah i'm sorry uh so this is very
informal so we're in a work session so
just hit me upside the head if i don't
recognize you
so all we are really going to be
considering is the
quote the the million dollars for the
feasibility study we wouldn't be trying
to include this entire thing into the
10-year plan at this time
but as we keep saying
it's a zero-sum game a million dollars
for that comes from somebody else
thank you
so we'll be working with the town like i
said um and we'll
more formally um estimate the cost it'll
still be approximate given
um the level of information that we
currently have available
and then we'll work with the town to
make sure they officially
submit something to the committee for
consideration
um so that was one of the follow-up
items um
i believe another topic that we wanted
to discuss today
was um
resiliency and some of the new federal
funds that are available
and so pete in preparation had put
together
um
some information
do you want to present them
i'm so going to turn it over to pete to
walk you through a document that he has
prepared
i just want to say you know we spend a
lot of time talking about bridge and
pavement condition with this committee
we as a department over the last several
years have been trying to build out our
inventory for all the other
highway assets that we own and are
responsible for and
we've embarked on a significant effort
to not only have an inventory of all of
our culverts and closed drainage systems
but also to have frequent inspection and
condition ratings for those and so we're
well positioned as we talk about how to
best utilize the
funding
and that's dedicated to resiliency in
the
the new federal infrastructure bill and
that's what pete's going to present
good morning
um
so this one page summary um hopefully it
hits all the high points of the
protect program and some of the funding
items along with a a plan which is uh i
believe is consistent with how we've
approached um
some of the other new funding that we've
received uh as it's applied to the to
the 10-year plan
so the the new uh
program is called protect and that's
promoting resilient operations for
transformative and cost-saving
transportation
and again the purpose of that of that
program is to help states improve the
resiliency of transportation
infrastructure
the funding um is uh like most other
funding is a 80 federal 20 match and
there is uh some language within the um
within the uh
the bill that would allow the match to
be reduced if you had
some um
developed a plan and implementation of a
resiliency improvement so um i think
we're on our on our way to
meeting those goals we're not there yet
but
you know this is the beginning of
our plan
[Music]
so it's formula funding and new
hampshire receives the annual
apportionment uh for this program and in
the first year of the reauthorization
it's 5.8 million dollars i believe in
2023 it's 5.9 million and change
there there is also um
discretionary grants that are associated
with this with this program
um and i've listed some of them here uh
resiliency improvement
community resilience and evacuation
routes and at-risk coastal
infrastructure and these again
are discretionary grants um that we'll
learn more about in the coming months we
don't know a whole lot about them at
this point
and so our plan um for the additional
funding
um we increase our crdr program that's
the culvert replacement rehabilitation
and drainage repair so that's a program
that we have currently
in uh the 10-year plan it is also in in
the draft that you have and and
we had
proposed to
include additional 2 million dollars
specifically from this protect
program
to bolster
that
culvert program so that we'd be able to
do more work
we know that there are lots of culverts
out there
and this will assist in
helping to replace some of those
culverts
i did provide a paragraph here under
number one that
explains what we've been doing over the
last couple of years to develop a
inventory a culvert inventory and a
drainage inventory statewide
and we've got it it's
right now we completed it
the end of the fall
of last year and it took us probably
three years to do it and and we
basically
put um
boots on the ground and um identified um
every culvert that we could find um and
geo-located it in in gis and
developed a an inventory
with attributes for each one of those
culverts and we also had a a fairly
rough uh culvert condition assessment
that was done and so um
5000 culverts and and we've got we've
got an initial inventory and the next
step in that process
is to do a more detailed culvert
inspection of for those culverts that
were identified as poor condition so
we've developed that we haven't we've
got a pilot program to uh implement
um to make sure that we're not we're
doing things that are
efficient um as a
from an inspection standpoint i mean
these can be labor intensive so we want
to make sure that
what we're doing before we implement it
is is is the right thing but we've got
that in place and we plan to implement
that this coming season spring season
from and and we'll use this uh inventory
in order to um prioritize our culvert
investment for that program so this is a
we've been doing it but this is more
formalized approach to identify those
culverts in in that are in in more so in
poor condition and also identify those
culverts that are um could use
resiliency um upsizing um in order to
meet the uh
the appropriate flows
um the second part of the plan um again
consistent with how we've approached
other new funding in in the 10-year plan
in this round
we identify existing projects that are
making resiliency investments
and
we are in the process of developing a
coastal flood risk tolerance framework
in order to again prioritize some of the
investments identify investments
that are
that are that we get the biggest bang
for the buck as we as we look at look at
sea level rise and also
rainfall intensity so this is more than
more than um
more than
sea coast related but that's kind of
that's that's a lot of the focus
so
again our plan would be to utilize the
crdr program for smaller size projects
and that's around less than five million
dollars again to uh for the resiliency
piece of those projects
um
and we would introduce individual
projects through the 10-year plan
process to address larger scale
investment needs
so we've established a dot review
committee
over the last couple of years which
really reviews uh new uh projects that
are being submitted by regional planning
commissions for in inclusion into the
ten year plan and this this committee
um would also take a look um at existing
projects and these new projects to
ensure that they are all
consider climate change and address
resiliency needs were appropriate so
we've got a second look at this
and we're
implementing
these responsibilities so that we um we
we cover the entire gamut of projects
that we do have in the plan
um i've identified
some of the projects that we
think would be a good fit that are
existing currently today in the in the
draft 10-year plan on the smaller side
we've got a a project in rye on 1a a
culvert replacement project
there's also a
culvert replacement project in gilmerton
on new hampshire 107 and we have
a number of colors two or three culverts
in shelburne on us2
that would fit
um the
existing projects that
are have resiliency components to them
um
there's also a
an engineering assessment for a bridge
in greenland which is included in in
this draft on new hampshire 33 over the
winnicott river
that would be appropriate for those
investments
some of the larger
projects and and where we see there's a
real opportunity
as these projects
the engineering is completed
to a greater level once we know more
about them that we could
position ourselves to be
well positioned for
applying for some of the discretionary
grants
that are available
hampton ocean boulevard is one of those
projects that we think would be
really well suited for discretionary
grant
there's also a seawall reconstruction
project that we've evaluated in
northampton on northampton rye
that would be a a good discretionary
grant project
and also we have a
an
interchange reconfiguration in in
hampton uh new hampshire 101 and us1
again larger scale project
that does have some um
that is impacted by sea level rise so
those are the types of projects that's
our a basic plan about how we would
approach the use of these funds
and it's also and again it's consistent
with how we've approached the additional
funding that we've received on the
federal side
can maintain those uh the prioritization
that's included in the in the 10-year
plan try to advance those projects and
utilize these new funds accordingly
representative ebal
thank you mr chair and thank you guys
for coming here i'm actually really
pleased to hear that you've done the
inventory of the culverts and that
you're looking closely at this
several years ago i served on a storm a
legislative stormwater commission and
we talked a lot about culverts and how
important they are in so many ways and i
think they're just sort of hidden and we
don't worry about them so much but they
play such a huge part
i'd be interested what do you mean by a
resilience component resilience
component i mean there's there's some
concern out there that we just keep
making our culverts bigger there are
other considerations
and then um i know one of the things
that we have talked about over the years
and i've read about is just
the effect on fish and you know and you
know so they're coming up with new
designs of culverts instead of just the
pipe their boxes so you get better flow
if you just talk a little bit about
those subjects as you seek to replace
culverts that would be great
so
um i guess all of that uh we consider
resiliency um you know uh sizing uh
would be more uh um
an upsizing for on the uh
you know in you know off the seacoast
inner new hampshire in in mountain areas
we've had a lot of large storms over the
summers that have done some serious
damage to our roads uh many of much of
that damage is some most uh associated
with undersized um culverts and and um
you know rivers that are raging want to
go where they want to go and so that
would be one of those areas that because
of rainfall intensity the increase in
rainfall intensity
we would seek to make sure that we
address those types of of
of changes as we look to
replace culverts that are that are aging
one of the things i would add is um
because we're oftentimes seeking federal
reimbursement for repairs that are done
in response to
a storm
we have all of that work
geo-located and mapped in gis so we know
which areas of the state have been
hardest hit when we've had
these significant rainfall events in the
summer months and so that helps inform
you know which infrastructure might need
to be evaluated from a resiliency
component
could you
could you speak a little bit to the the
issue of the
the design of the culvert of their pipes
if they're boxes and how that
works with uh fish you know rivers
streams that sort of thing
i'm just wondering about the designs um
so one of these projects that we have on
the list here the rye on new hampshire
1a culvert replacement
is one that we've partnered with the
nature conservancy they've done some
work up front to look at
tidal flows and one of the one of the
goals of that project was to improve uh
fist fish passage um overall
and so there's been a lot of hydraulic
work that's been done in order to
properly size that that culvert to
improve that situation but also not to
um
size it so that it doesn't have adverse
impacts
on the
inland side uh because of the tidal
flows so that's that's always a
challenge um
on the engineering's on the engineering
side and so
all of those factors uh come into play
size shape
um
the
natural bottom
of the of the the structure itself
because it's a work session i'm just
going to say i'm really familiar with
the tnc work and so that's sort of what
led to my question and um i'm glad to
hear you're working with them and taking
those things into consideration um i
would add that um
you know
resiliency um doesn't mean in all cases
that um you know it's the the solution
is raising the road to keep it out of
the water it's um so that that can be an
expensive proposition
um and also may not um
the road may be out of the water but
everything else is underwater so we try
to make it um
the the uh the retreat of the water and
the receding of the water um to be in a
in a place that we can we can utilize
that road in in a expeditious manner
without a lot of work so that would be
another goal of a resiliency program
thank you for them including
okay can you hear me
all right okay i have a question does
this program only apply to state roads
federally eligible federal so it doesn't
apply
further a follow-up question it doesn't
wouldn't be able to help municipal roads
right
we need to be a federally eligible uh
road okay good thank you very much thank
you mr chairman
thank you mr chairman
first of all thank you for
[Music]
providing this this is really good to
see that
it was interesting to see how you were
addressing uh
some of the money that's come through on
this
435 page
act that got put through the summary
uh one question i had is there's also
uh resiliency money in for the army
corps and in some cases it seems to have
overlapping
um
let's say need uh because there are some
places uh
even inland where there might be a uh a
need be both uh transportation wise and
army call wise to protect and sometimes
it's hard to know for sure which which
it is do you do you coordinate at all
with uh
whatever agency would be dealing with
the with the corps for some of these uh
grants that are also there's a lot of
them uh but by the core and even some by
uh by commerce
they're they're one of our uh partners
um so we do
you know we meet with with those
stakeholders core
um
epa on a monthly basis we have we have
monthly meetings with them and and we
would
coordinate um as necessary to get work
done and and look to leverage funds
okay thanks because there's some places
where it's it's debatable whether it's
it's a it's a core situation or it's a
it's a d.o.t situation so
okay and thanks again for providing this
information
thank you
um
with respect to hampton can you explain
a little more on what you
anticipate doing down in hampton
and i'm not a rep from hampton but i do
a lot of work down there and
i understand that area very well
so
for many years there's been discussions
about the need to reconstruct ocean
boulevard in the town of hampton
it's something that
the hampton beach area commission has
looked at
and then
a couple of 10-year plan cycles ago
there was a project introduced
at this point given the timing of when
the funds were programmed there really
hasn't been a significant amount of work
done yet we have started some of the
initial
data collection as i talked about for
the hudson project doing survey and
understanding where the existing
drainage infrastructure is the condition
that it's in
but we're only now
starting to meet with the town of
hampton to talk about
what their goal for the project would be
and exactly what we'd hoped to
accomplish there was a lot of advocacy
during this 10-year plan cycle
during the gasset phase
um
you know i think councillor stevens and
the governor both understand the
importance of the ocean boulevard
project but the challenge has been um
until we do some more design we really
reach agreement on what the scope is
it's hard to estimate what the true cost
would be and so similar to several other
projects in the 10-year plan our goal
over the next um
12 to 18 months is to really work with
the town understand exactly what the
scope is so either in the next 10-year
plan cycle we could
allocate a more appropriate amount of
money or as pete said
ocean boulevard in particular would be a
great candidate for some of these
discretionary grants at least from what
we know about these programs today and
we'd want to position new hampshire to
be able to compete to access those
dollars but we have to do more design
work to make sure we understand exactly
what the scope the cost and the schedule
would be
to be able to go after those dollars
and what would the impact on the park be
down there
with their parking lots and that along
route 1a
so these are all the factors that have
to be taken into consideration state
parks would be one of the stakeholders
working with us so we have an advisory
group already established with park
representation that we can hear from the
different impacted
stakeholders along the corridor yeah
because the impact on the park's parking
meter
operation would be dramatic if that's
changed and even you know construction
scheduling it's going to be an effort to
agree upon what the final
configuration should look like but
managing the construction and minimizing
the impact on the use of the beach each
season
is going to be something that's going to
have to be
thought through very carefully in
partnership with the town and all the
stakeholders
there's a drainage
at
boar's head
that
works into the
salt marsh behind
i think it's king's highway it's called
and those areas get flooded quite often
and i was asked by the town of hampton
three or four years ago to look at that
and see if there was a way we could
mitigate that to some extent we flew a
drone over it and
surveyed it and i basically what i told
them is the army corps
needs to be
involved in doing that marsh but the
problem is the drainage back to the
ocean
is restricted and would need to be
considered in your plan
because if that isn't made bigger you're
never going to stop the problem out
there
particularly with the phragmites weeds
explosion
but
just curious how those are going to work
out
thank you very much i appreciate it
mike
thanks ms chairman
yeah i wanted to comment on that
particular project we just did have a
pac meeting on that uh last week
and uh
it's um
it you know it's been
somewhat held up by the situation we've
had with kovid and been able to get
accurate you know traffic studies and
things but hopefully now it's gonna
they've said that we're really gonna get
going on that
but the uh
we do have money presently in
in the uh 10-year plan for this it's an
existing one and and that has been quite
a topic over the last couple ten years
playing you know when we've had our uh
you know hearings on it uh in hampton
and as a result of one of them a
previous one you know there was extra
money put into for design work so we
could design it pretty much get a pretty
good idea how much it was going to cost
all the way from the bridge down to high
street
and and you know that hopefully that
will
be uh
you know keep going and we'll get a
result of that because that was going to
give us hopefully you know a rough idea
what the price was because the one that
was done in in 18
uh had a price to it that was done by
the you know the hampton uh area
commission there and it was uh it was in
a range of 25 or 28 million at that time
you know just roughing it out for that
distance so we have a rough idea to know
that we're probably well short with the
roughly 9 million we have in so
hopefully we can get
as much as we can with not knowing
exactly what we're going to do get
get some type of an idea get that
engineering
that preliminary engineering done so we
can have that idea whether it's 30
million or 40 million or what because
there are some pretty complicated
things that have to be uh be resolved
especially with some of the rules we
have with you know drainage off of
highways and stuff so hopefully that
will that will get going and once we get
that idea we can see you know maybe
address the rest of it in the uh 10-year
plan but even better uh with this uh
with this program we have you know with
the feds with the protect
protect money at least for some of it
there's a lot of work to do and
hopefully and and we've been told we're
really going to get going on it now so
thank you
marty
thank you mr chairman thank you coming
back to hudson for a moment
am i understanding that the hudson
project was not the first time the rpc
got involved is after they had already
delivered the
priorities to the gasset and
i'm not clear on why we're
uh taking that out of the rpc
requirements and priority phase and
considering it at this time if i'm
understanding that timing correctly
um so you're correct representative um
hudson did not submit
the boulevard project as a candidate
when the rpcs conducted their
solicitation for projects to be
introduced into the 10-year plan
but many times communities miss that
window of opportunity
whether it's turnover and staff or other
factors just not knowing the process
and it's not unusual for us to get
requests like this in the house or
senate phase
so
this project isn't new in the sense that
there has been work done
and
that's why we'll do our best to bring
some information forward to the
committee for your consideration
and it's really not unusual for
individual members of the general court
to come before us with pet projects and
for us to have to decide what we're
going to do with them or not do it
with them
um
and in this case that in
many ways that's what's happening here
is that
they they brought it up
to the department but it's also been
brought up
uh by members of of uh the hudson
delegation to
the the new hampshire house so we were
going to hear it one way or another so
i'd rather have them have some kind of
background information for us next week
than just come in
uh cold from a
member of of the uh the house
but i agree it should have gone through
the process
so we can move on from the protect
program if there's no further questions
um so the other item
that sparked some discussion last week
was the capital corridor rail project
and there was specifically some
questions around how we were forecasting
the ridership
and should a rail service be established
between lowell
and manchester um so we have some
information to pass that on that today
i think there's been some
inaccurate reporting of data that the
department has been releasing through
the public process
as we've advanced what we're calling the
project development phase of the capital
corridor rail project
um the department completed a
feasibility study back in 2014
and of course
many things have changed since that time
whether it's the demographics of the
state
the models that
federal transit administration
encourages you use to forecast ridership
as well as of course the effects of the
covet 19 pandemic and so what we have
prepared and we'll pass out in a moment
is just a one pager that tries to make
this as close to an apples to apples
comparison as possible recognizing these
different factors um
and how things were estimated back in
2014 compared to today
i think one of the um
articles i had read after one of our
public meetings
in the feasibility study we talked about
round trips
and in some of our recent documentation
we've been talking about one-way trips
or the number of people that board a
train
and so that was why we thought it was
important especially after the questions
last week to put together this document
so we can pass that
out and i just want to stress in the
project development phase of the capital
corridor project is an ongoing effort
and so we've had a number of meetings
up until recently the focus was really
on identifying the exact locations of
the stations
as well as the layover facility in
manchester
our team
has been meeting with
folks from
massdot and the mbta
to understand exactly what the station
requirements would be
to meet their standards
and
we've been presenting our assumptions
around the service frequency
to get their concurrence as well
and so those conversations are ongoing
but we are getting closer now to being
able to estimate much more accurately
both the construction cost as well as
the operating expenses
and so we're now embarking on
the next portion of this phase of the
project which is to develop the
financial plan
and talk about how
we potentially would fund this project
of course we can't have a conversation
around funding without having that
accurate cost information
so the two pieces will now be advanced
in parallel as we refine the cost
estimates and finalize those we're
starting to talk about the different
federal programs that are available
and instead of just looking at how other
states have funded a rail project hone
in on really what would be feasible in
new hampshire
given
the current sources of revenue and the
current restrictions on the use of
different types of revenue
but we thought it was important to share
the ridership information because that
seemed to be what this committee was
most focused on when we met last time
but
just to reiterate what you
uh stated at one of our previous
meetings
the um
the study that is
being done at the moment
the preliminary planning
will not be completed until
2023 if i if i remember correctly
and
so that is
well beyond the the tenure of this
current general court
so
the money for that is currently within
the 10-year plan and it is all federally
funded
um
portion
uh for for the uh
um
for the
what was the term you used i'm trying to
remember
project development i had a problem with
that a couple years ago too
yeah so we try to avoid calling this
phase a study because we did the
feasibility study back in 2014 that's
what identified the preferred
alternative of a commuter rail service
up to manchester um so yes we call this
the project development phase so really
it's the engineering updating the
environmental permitting
and completing the financial plan to
really present information to the
legislature and decision makers so you
can decide how you want to move forward
or if you want to move forward with
construction
recognizing that
for a project of this size and scale
it's likely that we'd have to apply for
some of these discretionary grants they
are competitive that even if the state
wanted to move forward we'd have to go
through that process
and we may not be successful the first
time we apply
so there's a lot of uncertainty about
first of all would the project move
forward but even if there was support
from the legislature and others to do so
the exact timing because of
the way that it would likely be funded
thank you
any questions on
you've had a chance really quick to read
any questions on the handout
mr chairman
yeah do you know uh
thank you uh
uh commissioner when this
project development phase of the capital
korea project is to be done completed in
2023 any idea an exact date or even an
estimated date
we're targeting early in 2023 but an
exact date hasn't been established
um you know we're just starting the
financial planning work now
and
we're really reliant on
the cities of nashua and manchester and
all the stakeholders to meet with us and
help us vet these different options
um so
we'll know more about uh the exact sched
schedule as we get into the summer
months and we've had some of these
initial conversations
okay thank you thank you mr chairman
thank you commissioner
yes hi following up following up on that
what i've read is january but i don't
know when in january of 2023
that the project development phase
information will come in how does that
date or that month
in 2023
how does that dovetail with timing
for
applying for
monies and things in other words
just january um is that a good time to
be ready to go and then then you have to
be putting something forward before
spring summer fall
i think it's really premature to
talk about
when is a good time to start applying
for those funds
our task was to complete this project
development phase to provide the much
needed information and exact cost data
to decision makers
we estimate how long it would take to
complete that effort and especially you
know with the pandemic
um it's been challenging to conduct some
of those meetings so we're targeting
early 2023 to complete the work
um but until we see how
the final product is received um we
don't know whether or not there might be
changes in statute that are required
we don't know the exact timing of when
some of these discretionary grant
opportunities might be
moved forward so there's a lot of
question marks still we just have to
complete this work and we ask for folks
to be patient um to let us
conclude the design effort so that we
have accurate costs to really inform the
discussion thank you
thank you very much
no other questions on what was presented
about
a little bit on the capital corridor
if not
i think there
might be one or two other items if i
remember correctly
i think we've covered everything that
was discussed during our work session
last week
i think the one other item that we were
asked to provide information on was the
ongoing maintenance costs associated
with continental boulevard
and so i'm gonna actually ask bill cass
to share some information
um this is continental boulevard in the
town of merrimack for those of you who
aren't familiar with that location
i think all the veteran members are
cognizant of continental boulevard
ah good morning william cass assistant
commissioner i think the question was uh
what is our general maintenance cost
annual maintenance cost for maintaining
uh continental boulevard so we maintain
continental boulevard from
exit 10 out to the old camp sergeant
road and down to um 101a
it's about
2.8 miles and
our estimate is it's about 80 000 a year
of annual maintenance which is primarily
the uh winter maintenance plowing salt
use things like that
i haven't we haven't factored in uh
you know
annual repaving or things like that but
just for an order of magnitude
it was last resurfaced in 2017
typically that
level of built road would have a cycle
of about once every every 10 years so
it's relatively new pavement about
halfway through its uh service life and
it was about
uh hundred thousand dollars in 2017 to
uh pave that um with a maintenance
one-inch overlay so that gives you an
order of magnitude
in the future or sometime you could
either annualize it or if it needs to be
resurfaced at some point in the future
would be
you know about that amount with
whatever inflation would be in
the next five years or something like
that so
hopefully that answers gives you the
information you look uh and
just clarify that is all turnpike funds
that goes into that
does that mean yes that's all turnpike
funds that maintain that section of um
and and we just took down the tollbooth
at exit 10 which helped to pay that
i appreciate you doing that on on
semi-quick notice so that we at least
have
an idea if we discuss what we want to do
with
um the effie everett and widening and
and
it's all in there and what we want to do
with continental boulevard which will be
an item of discussion
here later today
and bill william
excuse me
commissioner cass while you're sitting
there um
along with the commissioner
um
we've had a lot of discussion over the
last couple weeks about sound walls yes
and the rules and everything else
is there any utility
to
having some kind of study committee
to look at the rules
are are
you
continually upgrading them uh revising
them based on federal guidance and the
rest i'm trying to satisfy
several members around this table
some of them who are here and some of
them who are not
as to
what is eligible what is not eligible
whether or not we should include
schools
in the process those types of things i i
just don't know
what whether it would be useful to have
some kind of legislative study
of the whole all the rules or if gelcar
handles that adequately for as in
regards to
your process
so
i know there's been a lot of interest in
the topic of sound walls you know we as
a department want to be good neighbors
and we
strive to mitigate the impacts of our
projects and so we do follow closely
what's happening nationally and federal
guidelines
as we develop our noise policies
um so you know we're happy to continue
to work with the legislature if you
think a study committee would be
a good opportunity for us to help
educate
on the process that we do follow
and how our thresholds were established
then certainly we'd welcome that
opportunity to help people understand
the work that we do
if the intent is to
provide recommendations to the
department or to modify our policy
we're still limited in what we can
change because of the federal
requirements and i've said this before
um
you know while there's advocacy when
we're doing these type 1 projects you
know where we're widening a highway and
as part of that we're mitigating noise
if there's advocacy for broadening
the scope and building more sound walls
as part of those projects
well then that's increasing the list of
people who would be eligible for a sound
wall elsewhere in the state but we don't
happen to be doing a project at this
time
and so
we've really strongly encouraged the
legislature to think about funding that
type 2 program there are a lot of people
who live along highway corridors that if
we were building a project today they
would qualify for a sound wall
and so from an equity perspective
the department has said many times you
know we would
welcome the opportunity to start funding
some of those type 2 projects
but that seems to sometimes be
overlooked because the focus is on
expanding the scope of the projects that
we are completing today
and
the one last thing i would note and i
shared it with um representative query
who had questions i can share with you
or the rest of the committee i think it
was
around 2015 2016 with some uh
bills in the legislature there was a
there was a um study commission the the
report is still um on the legislative
website um
that made that that
may provide some
of that background information there was
a legislative committee about
yeah six seven years ago
oh thank you
um yes um
uh thank you for
sharing that information but um you also
said
uh commissioner that
you were gonna distribute a map showing
the
i apologize yes we have packets we'll
pass them out now um showing the exact
limits of the uh
project on 95 and the sections of sound
wall that would be constructed
if
and if you could just point out
to us commissioner
where this area where the
school
is what page is that on
sure so the the first page is the is a
broad overview of 93 with a
i mean 95 excuse me where um it splits
to the turnpi um spalding turnpike going
north the portsmouth traffic circle and
kind of the middle of that first
document
95 associated kind of um
it's
left to right across the across the page
which is south south to north
so it's part of the um project to um
consider uh using the shoulders over the
high level bridge and that actually
goes from about the traffic circle to
exit um
to in
maine
is where we're looking at um
we call dynamic or or on shoulder use
dynamic shoulder running
where um we're going to be deploying
some
its to allow um
traffic to run on the shoulders during
periods of high traffic volume and and
ease some of the congestion over the
high level bridge so associated with
that project we were obligated
to do a uh noise analysis in the whole
area so this kind of summarizes that so
we looked at
um
you know seven or eight different
neighborhoods along that whole corridor
and that's what these maps again the
maps kind of follow from
south to north
so if you look at
for example
on figure
eight which is study area three it's
about the fourth page in
second page fourth page double-sided
and it's in the bottom right that it
that it shows the uh figure eight
that is one of the areas um which was a
now and analyzed that is um
panaway manor
um that is an area that that has um
strong justification and meeting the
requirements for a sound wall so that's
why that one is is is showing green and
it shows the details of the number of
benefited receptors and all of that it's
the numbers are there if you want to
look closer but that's one of the
two areas that did
qualify for a sound wall if you look at
the next page figure nine there's
another little neighborhood there um
and that conceptual sound wall there is
shown as as orange
that is an area that didn't meet the um
that didn't meet the requirements of our
policy so we did evaluate it and it is
not getting a sound wall
if you turn to
the next page
which is figure 10
and the next three pages kind of cover
the same area so figure 10
figure 11
and figure 12.
that is the area that we have been
talking about on the west side of 93 or
the top of the page is the area around
um
it's rockingham ave is the closest is
the is the closest there
um that is an area that qualifies for a
sound wall and and will be proposing
building a sound wall
on the east side of 95 through that area
um
which is the bottom half of that page
you can see um just coming out of just
north of the traffic circle there is a
school there and that is one of the
areas on particularly
figure 12
where
it's shown as orange that was the
concept that was the sound wall area
that that we looked at
and again based on the policy that is
one of the areas that didn't meet the
reasonableness criteria and we're not
proposing a sound wall there so that's a
general area and some of the
background i could answer more details
but that gives you the orientation of
what it is
hopefully
representative newman
thank you
i'm the
figure
figure eight on on the study area three
is that the is that the pan away manner
is that the development that has been
maybe there's others but is that the one
that's been waiting for 30 years
yes yes thank you
yeah that neighborhood predates the
widening of 95. so that's one of the
locations it was the highest priority
when we looked at locations that would
qualify for a type 2
program and this was one of the highest
priorities in terms of the cost benefit
associated with mitigating noise so it's
just now that we're considering the
shoulder running that we can go back and
look at the noise criteria but
technically they qualified even without
the shoulder use
but we didn't have the funds for a type
2 program
so now they get to be type 1 because
we're doing work on 95.
thank you
can you explain
and i noticed that some of this is near
the airport
runway how how does the
model
take into account both sort of the
constant noise of the highway operation
and the
occasional perhaps greater noise from
airport operations
uh and
i mean obviously i think you know
noise barrier is not going to help with
the latter but
how does that
has a different level of noise impact
get
considered in the model
it's primarily looked at
as analyzing and
evaluating the highway noise impact
it's calibrated to the existing
conditions so
the modeling
of the highway noise is is set with
respect to the overall ambient
environment so
any
present existing
noise generators like the airport are
taken into account in the
establishment of the background of the
of the overall ambient noise and then
once the model is calibrated
it evaluates um you know the projected
noise with increase in traffic volume
and you know 20 years in the future and
with and without noise barriers to
evaluate
what the noise reduction would be
for the proposed barriers and and
and do that analysis and
analysis and evaluation
so essentially
it doesn't directly take into account
the um
the airport or other noise
generators but it does indirectly in the
calibration of of the model to the
existing environment
thanks mr chairman
um
just just a quick review if you just
give me the page numbers of the is it
just two of them that you're approving
at this time
because you mentioned a lot about the
various ones but
yes yeah they're just the two the one at
panaway manor which was figure eight
that uh representative newman had
pointed out
and um
figure 10 and 11 which is uh
we've been
dubbing at the um rockingham avenue area
because rockingham avenue is kind of the
closest there by woodman ave but it
covers
rockingham avenue and edmond avenue so
it's the west side of
of 93.
thank you just just just an observation
i pointed out the one on figure
9 that didn't qualify typically we find
there needs to be
and this is
somewhat anecdotal but it's but it's
you know a fairly
dense neighborhood like panaway manor
like rockingham ave on the west side
that is
you know runs longitudinally parallel to
the facility that tends to have the
density that tends to have
the reasonableness to
to
um merit noise mitigation
um the individual houses or the
individual streets that tend to come
down and dead end at the highway with
four or five streets at the end of it
that those typically don't
have the have the density to qualify for
for noise barriers and they're
even on the area of the school
there are several of those neighborhoods
um like myrtle avenue and stuff there
are smaller clusters of
of houses in a smaller neighborhood
but again at um
four or five six houses at the end of
the street they don't tend to meet the
cost for reasonableness criteria to
build a wall so
and sometimes the
the visual of the aerial mapping can can
kind of
point that out more than the specific
numbers it's very good thank you
we appreciate the work that went into
these
visual representation of what we're
doing because
sound walls are going to continue to be
an item of discussion
not just in the house and the senate but
with the public at large
i can only imagine what will happen when
we finally get around to widening the
effie everett uh
it will be a lot of the same questions
about wine here and why not there
um so i think that it it is good that
the
this committee at least is getting
a better handle on the criteria
um
even if
some of us think that
uh within our own communities that it
should have been built and they just
don't meet the criteria
but at least we understand why
and i think that's important
uh marty
uh thank you uh some years ago there was
a hearing on the on the widening project
and at exit 8 there was a set of
residents who were
as upset as the ones in bedford
i remember that harry
barry additional question thank you
um
are there some
non-noise wall
solutions that could be funded out of
highway funds i'm thinking
especially considering the school a
double painting or triple painting
windows and other
noise mitigations that are
not
on the highway but
but are closer to the receptor they
are they eligible or has anybody
considered those as an alternative
one of the one of the things with with
highway noise and and the federal policy
is is is it's a geared at
mitigating noise in the outside
environment it's not necessary to
mitigate highway noise inside there are
some there are some
elements of that but
from a highway noise perspective
the um
it's it's extremely it's it's it's never
really met i mean when they're talking
about insulating windows and stuff like
that that are that is usually more
associated with
um you know very high noise generators
like like a jet taking off in the
proximity of an airport so most of our
policy is geared at
protecting um noise barrier for uh
for noise mitigation for the outside uh
environment around uh around residential
houses or or public space
but yeah the one thing with that with
that said and
there are some mitigating elements that
we do try to
institute
a lot of areas along 93 and even areas
here along 95 this rockingham boulevard
or panaway manor they have been areas
that have had
noise issues for a long time and we have
we have
noted that we can't
it doesn't um meet the criteria to um
uh rationalize using
you know constructing big sound walls
but we have installed privacy fences
stockade fences that at least from a
visual
kind of thing provide some some buffer
and barrier um
you mentioned the teaberry lane there in
bedford i mean one of their other
concerns and the noise was you know
people accessing their backyard from the
highway and stuff so we at least tried
to
mitigate that so there are some
strategies um like that we have
mentioned that in portsmouth and in
other areas
um
but they haven't been
i've heard people say they don't want
the consolation prize they want a noise
wall so that's
anything else
on sound walls at this point
see now i think commissioner that that
was all that we asked you
to to bring forward to answer questions
from members of the committee if i'm
looking at my list right
that was everything that i had for the
group um unless i missed something the
rest of the team can keep me straight
and
there was some one-off questions not
related to the 10-year plan with certain
members of the committee but nothing
10-year plan specific beyond what we
talked about already
what i would like to do at this point
is take a 10 minute break by the clock
on the wall
and then come back and we'll start with
what the commissioner
is going to ask us to put into the
10-year plan as far as
bonding
expenditure authority and and the rest
on
there there is some boilerplate that
goes into every
um
10-year plan
and we'll go over that and then i
there at least a couple of amendments
that i want to discuss
and
we shouldn't be here all day so if we
could take a 10 minute break
mike what
if i could ask one quick question on 10
year plan a continuation of a question i
had last time
why don't we wait until after the break
they're not going anywhere
you
okay if we could reassemble
and
the
commissioner handed out
some paperwork that explained toll
credits
and her response to
the city of keene when they asked to to
use them
quickly if anybody has any questions
about that
see none uh
mike andrew you had a question
thanks john
oh yes the question i had was uh
relative to uh the 10-year plan the
portsmouth kittery
the route 1 the room bypass
the basically it's the
the bridge it says bridge replacement
but it
it's for the
marine dock
replacement that uh
that d.o.t committed to
and i guess i just want to confirm it i
uh as far as the money that this is
with this
million um you know in the 4 million we
gave for this in the previous 10 year
plan
that the uh that this is sufficient to
do this particular project which is to
make the port authority hole for the
removal of their big barge that these
budge pier they used to have
no um
one of the delays in that and that has
been delayed has been that the costs
have escalated
whether the initial estimate was too
conceptual or not um but
we have
um what we have programmed in the
10-year plan
is um
is
is shy of uh what it's going to cost to
replace that that has been one of the
hang-ups
about two years ago 2019 as they came in
with 66 percent
level plans
the cost estimate jumped from around 19
million to closer to 30 million and now
the current estimate is around 32 to
34 million um
so we have been working with the with
the port they're managing the project uh
to help uh address that
um and talking to some of the
policymakers in the governor's office to
make sure everybody's on the on the same
page so
for the
uh roughly
14 million dollar shortfall
we had through the budget process last
year uh
solicited capital budget funds of four
million dollars to be able to
uh provide a match to a federal grant um
a raise grant we went after the we went
after the grant we just found out at the
end of
december that we were unsuccessful in
that grant however with the passage of
the
infrastructure law we feel we do have
capacity with our federal funds to make
up that gap so we're proposing
to um
meet that shortfall with fy22 federal
dollars so about 14 million dollars of
additional authority that came in this
federal fiscal year and fy22
uh to allow us to advertise that project
and fully fund it so that's why
and i'm being precise about fy22 because
the 10-year plan
depicted there shows the projects and
the funding from fy 23 through
32.
so
but the federal bill that was passed the
additional infrastructure
funding um
does
does start flowing hopefully if
everything else passes that's another
issue in fy
beginning in fy 22. so we're
we're planning to use
um
additional federal funding in federal
fiscal year
22 to advertise the project this summer
and fully fund it and get it completed
so the current estimate as i said is
around
30 32 to 34 million dollars i know it
was 32 million dollars a year ago when
we had really put nuts to it but
as it advertises this year it may be a
little bit more inflation in the current
bidding environment but so that's um
that's what we're um estimating
okay thanks so
you you're basically saying that you you
feel confident that you're going to be
able to have the money do that
if if we pass it this this amount right
here now in a 10-year plan
so the project we consider to be fully
funded with federal formula funds
i would be remiss if i didn't just
asterix all of our federal funds um so
while it was um a relief from a
transportation perspective to see an
infrastructure bill passed
at the end of last calendar year
um we are still working under a
continuing resolution from an
appropriations perspective
and so we have not received authority to
spend all of the money that was in the
infrastructure bill
um the current uh continuing resolution
expires
mid-february
and so there's been a lot of advocacy
from
our industry as a whole
that
instead of
turning the faucet parcel pars
partially on and only releasing a
portion of the funds that we really need
to be able to obligate all of the money
that was
anticipated to be spent in that first
year of the infrastructure bill and so
we have received some of the one-time
money we got our full 45 million of
annual distribution of say the bridge
funds but we've only been receiving
a portion of our authority
when it comes to the traditional formula
funds so really it's five and a half
twelfths of authority you know the
federal fiscal year starts october
through
mid february is sort of five and a half
months worth of authority and it's not
based on the levels in the
infrastructure bill it's level funding
last year's appropriations
so they have not increased it so
honestly representative we would
like to fund
fully the port work in 2022 because it's
going to be for all state dots and our
partners a struggle
if they do turn the faucet back on to
obligate all of the first year money
between now and the end of september so
the timing of this couldn't be better
that's our hope is that
um they lift the continuing resolution
we get the full funding and then this
project is well-timed be able to take
advantage of the first year's dollars
thank you very much thanks john
okay commissioner you also handed out
um the language that you need
to update rsa237-2
does everyone have a copy i think we
were a couple short maybe we got some
extras made
um so not a lot from us this year um
the first paragraph is just the standard
language
stating that the legislature would be
adopting the 10-year plan
and then
as the chair had indicated earlier
every year
as we advance the 10-year plan we have
to update the authority associated with
the turnpike system to reflect the value
of the projects that are programmed in
the 10-year plan
so what's included
is
the required changes to the
dollar figures
associated with our construction
improvements
but that's all that we have at this time
we would anticipate bringing forward
some language with respect to the
circumferential highway and hudson
boulevard should that be something the
committee wants to entertain
and we are still going through other
statutes to see if there's anything
that doesn't necessarily pertain to a
project but pertains to how we advance
projects where
in the past we've
done this we've included
enabling language in the 10-year plan
bill
to allow us to implement efficiencies or
do things differently and we've also
reached out to the transportation
council which is a legislatively
legislatively established body that
works with the dot
um there might be some minor changes
they want to make to their authorities
to provide better clarity around their
roles and responsibilities so we might
bring that forward next week but at the
moment this is all that we really have
to include
okay we would we would appreciate
especially if you need
any language to give you some latitude
in what
year you actually do projects based upon
permitting
funding and all the rest which we've
included in prior
prior terms
to make sure that things continue
forward even if a particular project
gets hung up for some reason
so anything we're going to bring forward
other than maybe project language for
hudson
um would be something that would walk
the committee through if there wasn't
time for you to incorporate the
amendment we'll introduce it in the
senate phase but of course we'd want to
present it make sure you're aware of it
and that there was support
okay
um this time
is there any discussion on that the
language that that they need at this
point
and any objection to that being included
as an amendment to the 10-year plan
seeing none
everybody hold your peace uh it will be
included
in in a an amendment that the committee
will look at next week
now i do have
one well i have actually two but let's
take up the first one first
this is amendment uh 0 2
1 h i have cough drops dead
it's to amend uh the bill
uh and in essence it is ownership
transfer
that is part of the the project of
widening fe ever
turnpike project number 13761
it provides that the commissioner
shall transfer ownership of the
state-owned portion of continental
boulevard in merrimack to the town of
merrimack not later than july 1st 2025.
i bring this forward
as a proposed amendment
based on the fact that one we just took
down the toll booth at exit 10
and two
you heard the figures that that uh
commissioner cass gave us about
annual maintenance of that 2.8 million
2.8 miles of road plus the 700 000 we
spent not long ago
resurfacing
resurfacing that
so
what's the will of the committee on this
remember this is straw poll it will be
put into an amendment
and the entire committee will be
will be discussing that at executive
sessions
however we need to to move forward
um with this
i would ask the commissioner
it i know it's a policy commissioner
policy decision commissioner but but it
is the date doable
i believe that date would be
appropriate
like i said i understand that it's a
policy decision that that
but i'm not saying do it tomorrow um
because it would take some negotiations
with
um
the town and the rest
any discussion marty
thank you i'll just make the additional
point that any money that would have
been spent on continental boulevard is
money that's not spent on other things
the town of merrimack might want like
the widening project
thank you
uh
john
all right i have a question and i just
want to be clear about this uh when i
first came to this committee we've dealt
with the merrimack tolls ever since i've
been on this committee it's a long time
i believe there were three
uh three tolls
now have we removed or there be in the
process of removing all the tolls i
um
yes
and it's always been done in the senate
as part of if i remember correctly as
part of uh the budget process and not
the the highway fund we started with 12
then took out 11 and this time in house
bill two we took out the the tolls at um
exit 10. um so there are no further
tolls
ramp tolls in the town of merrimack
commissioner
um i will just clarify
that um
not only did we zero out the toll
um
at all three locations
in terms of what infrastructure remains
so
exit 12 has been removed entirely with
the exception of the maintenance
building
exit 11
we demo demoed the toll plaza we still
have the maintenance building
exit 10
the toll was zeroed out
on new year's eve and so we still have a
toll plaza at that location we plan to
demolish that
this construction season
so then officially all three toll plazas
will be gone but there is still a
physical plaza at exit 10 we have not
completed that work yet
there's still the physical building at
12 too so that's
i guess is part of the whole
proposal to to redo that but
mr chair
mr chair in order to get the straw poll
moving i will move ought to pass on your
amendment
two eight one h a second
okay
and again it's a straw poll it's not the
final decision
of the committee because we have to have
the entire amendment in front of us
all of those in favor of incorporating
this into
a committee amendment for house bill
signify by saying aye
opposed nay the eyes have it and we'll
see what happens with the full committee
thank you i do have a second one wait uh
mr chair
sorry yes
for the record um i just like an
estimate of the annual tolls that have
been are lost because we've removed 10
11 and 12.
and i'd also like an estimate of the
cost of removal the infrastructure
i believe those are already part of
the planning process in in the turnpike
portion
as far as the cost of
removing
um
the structures at 10. we've already done
11 and i forget what that cost us last
year
but um yeah it was
but what we're losing in revenue
um i think that's a fair question
we have all of that information readily
available and because this matter was
taken up many times by the legislature
we provided testimony so we can share
the cost of removal of 12 what we spent
removing 11
the budgeted cost for removing 10
and what we anticipate the cost of
removal of the buildings will be but
that work will be done as part of the
effie everett widening
making a distinction between the toll
operations
and the plazas themselves and then the
administration building at each location
and then the last revenue we can share
um what the total was from
closing all three facilities
the idea here is to just show
the cost of removal plus the loss of the
tolls versus the costs of continental
boulevard i mean it's just i think it's
good for establishing the record
all right thank you
i didn't get to that did we get to oh
yeah we did get to the straw throttle
okay the second one that is being
proposed
is zero two
six one h and when somebody makes sure
that the commissioner has a copy of it
this proposed
changed to
[Music]
the bedford merrimack
project 16
which is the mainline toll plaza
which is in the
current 10-year plan
to be
turned over to all electronic towing
and
the removal of the current toll
facilities that stretch across the fv
everett this amendment
amends that particular project
that the
mainline toll plaza which will be all
electronic towing
move to the vicinity of the current exit
10 on the fe average turnpike
and
the rationale for this is
primarily
right now
it is easy to circumvent if um
the main line at bedford
um if you want to do that
uh and second we are not capturing
any of the traffic that is going to
uh the airport
we have to move it far far enough away
from
uh resort way
um so that we don't owe money back to
the feds because that was built with
federal highway funds
we could build it
as currently envisioned at where it is
now
or we move it further south to capture
um that traffic there
i think that
it's not going to change the cost
i mean no matter what we do we're going
to have to put up a gantry for
all electronic tolling
and also then tear down
the
current
bedford main mainline toll
am i correcting
the roughly equivalent
cost analysis
commissioner
yes we'd have to do some additional
borings and determine the exact location
of
the gantry should the plaza be relocated
but essentially yes from
we have to build a gantry
along the turnpike to replace the
existing toll plaza so we'll just be
moving it to a different location
you can't hang it from the bridge
what is the
thoughts of the committee on this
proposal
i will i will remind everybody that two
years ago this was included in the house
version of the 10-year plan when it
was supposed to be going to the senate
uh but then it got uh
death by covid uh
so
um
it was not a new subject nor a new
matter that this committee has dealt
with
mr chairman i move out to pass on
amendment 2022-0261-h
uh representative clutier has
uh moved that
this
uh
zero two six one h be included in the
committee amendment on
uh house bill
any discussion
it's been seconded by multiple people
representative edgar representative
mills among them
any discussion
representative newman
yes mr chairman i just want to
understand this would be
oh lord the north and south it would be
it would be
north then of exudate and south of the
current ten
i i
this
kind of leaves it up to the commissioner
and her department to the physical
setting that it says within the vicinity
it could be a little north of it a
little south of it depending on land and
where the best possible
sighting of that would be i'm not trying
to specify what mile marker or
or what because that that gets into
micromanaging um the engineering of the
whole thing which this committee has
never done
and so i would interpret this to be that
you want a toll plaza between
exit 8 and exit 11. you're not
specifying exactly where but
the intent is to capture traffic from
exit 6 or sorry exit 10 upwards so we
wouldn't put it before
exit 8 and we probably wouldn't put it
after exit 11 we would find the
appropriate location
within the vicinity of exit 10. and that
and that's kind of the way i envisioned
it when we discussed it two years ago
and when i was looking at it again this
year
not trying to hamstring the department
on the exact location
but of course two years ago we were
still planning on having exit 10 as a
toll
raft
thank you the other nice thing about the
all electronic is it it takes a lot less
it takes a lot less footprint and
they're a lot cheaper to construct so
the citing
citing possibilities would be greater
given that you just have to
find enough space to put the
put the post to put the gadgetry on
and i'm in support of this
uh it it had when i first moved to the
state there was a
there was a main line toll at exit 11
and uh that course is no longer there
but this is similar to where that would
be
and when i was growing up the effie
everett ended at what is now exit five
however lisa
uh just a quick procedural question i'm
puzzled by these two amendments being
introduced by exactly the same language
we're not the first the second one that
we pass replace them
um no at this point
with these are only straw polls
if the committee approves both of them
and we've already approved what the
commissioner has requested be included
i take them over to um
legislative services they take all three
language and put them into the right
format so
there is only one amendment that comes
out
at in the the final analysis
on house bill
which is a committee report to the house
of representatives
thank you
so
all those in favor did we
um
ready for the vote thank you mr clerk um
all those in favor of the adopt of the
inclusion
of uh
zero two six one h
into
uh
uh committee amendment on house bill
2022 signify by saying aye
posney the eyes have it and it will be
incorporated into that
that is all
that anybody has brought to me
i ask that it be done today so that we
could do on a committee report
understanding that something may come up
at the public hearing
next week
we still have an executive session
scheduled for that day
i will tell the committee this
if you looked at the calendar on the
february 24th i have a continued
executive session on house bill 2022
that will stay in the calendar
i am going to expand that
to include the two bills that we have
not exact both of which deal with
laconia
the sale of the laconia facility
um
and we will do those on the 24th so that
everybody can plan on being here
rather than just
um well we'll catch him on the fly that
worked for the first few but it's not
working at the moment and i want to
finish everything by the end of the
month
so with that commissioner do you have
anything that
you want to say
ask us to do not do
as always i'd like to recap the action
items for the department um
so i
i think we just have the one request
from representative ebel to provide
the loss in revenue from removing the
three plazas in merrimack as well as the
cost of removal of those plazas and
buildings
and was there anything else that the
committee requested of the department
and representative we'll email you our
suggested language for
the amendments you can incorporate it
into
one format we just have the hard copy
here but we can send you the electronics
now the the the hard copy is fine
commissioner because i i just take them
over
and and uh
the very able people at legislative
services will take it all and put it
into the
to the right language and no
numbering and not and all the rest
um so the only other action is to
continue working with hudson
to identify
what the scope of work would be so they
could bring forward their request at the
public hearing next week
all right thank you very much
anything else if the committee wants to
discuss
about
the 10-year plan
the process or where we go from here
i will say that i've already heard from
members of the coast delegation as well
as as their uh
county commissioners
that they will be here
uh
next week to talk about
um one road
uh
at the balsams
um
and that's why we have the public
hearings for people to be able to come
in
and with the
way things have gone with the with um
the pandemic
which is why we're having a continued
public hearing just to make sure that
people have been able to get in and talk
so there is that
and
whomever else might show up
commissioner again we thank you all um
i know you bring a lot of your staff
over here
uh to try to answer our questions and
and i can't express our appreciation
in any stronger terms than that it
really
does help to be able to to look at
things and knowing that we'll be able to
get answers
thank you very much
and see no further comments
from the committee
um
oh representative claudia
to be sure to
you're going to have the a public
hearing on house bill 2022
next week and a possible executive
session on the same bill
it is in the calendar that way we will
start if we can't agree on a committee
amendment
we'll be back
and no matter what we'll be back on the
24th for the other two bills
on thursdays right that's
uh
the goal is if we
we meet next week
and then
house session the week of the 15th
and then the 24th we meet
uh finish up uh
the 10-year plan if we if required the
other two bills that we're still in
possession of
the committee and then we're finished
until we get senate bills
okay i just saw in other words basically
the hopefully the target date to finish
with all the house bills is february
24th is that correct that's correct
and the committee is
this work session
of public works
committee is
adjourned
you